President Trump spoke briefly to
reporters yesterday but did not answer
questions
he plans to hold a news conference later
today five members of Congress close to
the president now say they're in self
quarantine because they had contact with
someone who tested positive for
coronavirus Paula Reid is at the White
House Paula does the president plan to
get tested a good morning Michelle
president Trump traveled with one of
those self quarantine lawmakers
yesterday on Air Force One another one
is the president's incoming chief of
staff but the White House says the
president has not been tested because he
has not come into contact with anyone
who has tested positive and they say
he's not exhibiting any symptoms
his blindsided the world and I think
we've handled it very very well amid
mounting criticism of his
administration's response to an outbreak
that has been moving across the globe
for nearly three months President Trump
once again tried to reassure Americans
we will be taking care of the American
public the president previously said he
thought the US economy was resilient
enough to weather the fallout of
coronavirus but now he says he's seeking
a very substantial relief including help
for hourly wage earners and a possible
payroll tax cut even a one percentage
point reduction in the payroll tax could
cut up to 75 billion dollars in revenue
in a sign of how quickly pressure is
mounting we think we will get out of
this more than months just this past
Friday the president's top economic
adviser Larry Kudlow had pushed against
big stimulus packages the administration
is also considering relief for airlines
and the cruise industry but Democrats
say the White House should prioritize
help for individuals before corporations
which is about the families who about
putting families first if your
children's school is closed
trying to take care of them at home at
least five members of Congress have now
self quarantined after interacting last
month with an individual at the
Conservative Political Action Conference
or CPAC who later tested positive for
coronavirus they include the president's
incoming chief of staff mark meadows
George's Doug Collins who shook
president Trump's hand Friday ahead of a
visit to the CDC and Florida's Matt
gates who flew with the President on Air
Force One just yesterday gates tweeted a
photo of himself wearing a gas mask
while he signed the coronavirus funding
bill it's unclear exactly what the
appetite is among Republicans for a
payroll tax cut these are meant to put
more money in workers pockets but some
economists question whether that kind of
stimulus would work in this situation or
most people are trying to stay home and
not spending as much money Tony
Paula thank you very much